Do you remember Wingdings?
>> [LAUGH].
>> That weird font that was
oddly popular in the 90's?
Have you ever wondered why a font
like that would even exist?
>> Well, as it turns out,
it's possible to build a font family
made of images and
icons rather than letters.
Now, icon fonts provide
a fantastic option for
the little images and
icons that often decorate websites.
There's an icon font
I like called Zocial.
Now, this font is free and
open source, so
I could download it and
serve it from my site.
However, the font is publicly available
from the font site itself so,
I'll use that instead.
Let's see it in action.
Notice that I've added some
shadow to the font icons.
This file looks a bit complex so,
bear with me.
Here's what's going on.
The icon font characters are added
using the CSS before selector.
I've added some formatting to that
as well including CSS text shadow.
Now that rule is applied to
every element whose class
name begins with zocial.
And you can see that each of
the list items has a class
with a name made up of zocial and
a brand name.
Now, at the top,
you'll see an @import url,
that points to an external CSS file.
Let's look at that now, the @font-face
url, at the top of this gives the source
of the actual font files and
there's some variations available there.
And what you see below that
are selectors based on class names like
the ones we've used, zocial-flickr,
zocial-laughter and so on.
For example, set the class
zocial-flickr on an element and
the character F will be
displayed before it.
Which in the zocial font
is the flickr logo.
Clever, huh?
Icon fonts have a number of advantages,
over plain old images.
They're vector graphics that
can be infinitely scaled and
an entire set of images can
be downloaded in one font.
And this makes them a great potential
solution for responsive designs where
you require minimum downloads and
maximum scalability.
Now, if you look at
the resources required for
the weloveiconfonts site,
you can see that the total wait for
that hundred of images from all
the fonts on the page is less than 300k.
Icon fonts have a number of
advantages over plain old images.
They're vectorgraphics that
can be infinitely scaled.
An entire set of images can
be downloaded in one font.
This makes them a great potential
solution for responsive designs where
you require minimum downloads and
maximum scalability.
The example here shows lots of
different options for icon fonts.
And of course the characters
in icon fonts behave
just like letters in other fonts.
So you can resize and color them and
use other CSS effects,
just like you would with text.
There are lots of tools for
creating icon fonts and
lots of pre-built icon fonts.
Check out the links below the video.
There's also a link to information
about improving accessibility
by using Aria attributes